sunny beaches flashy bars romantic
waterfalls tom cruise's lowest rated
rotten tomatoes movie may typify cheesy
80s cinema but that doesn't mean it's
all bad in fact the bar themed cocktail
is actually worth watching here's why
tom cruise is one of the biggest movie
stars in the world and that's been the
case for a very long time the actor rose
to prominence in the 1980s thanks to
movies such as risky business and top
gun both of which amassed plenty of
favor among fans and critics alike that
said some of cruz's biggest hits from
his breakout decade haven't enjoyed
similar to claim cocktail released in
1988 was a financial success but the
movie was savage by critics as evidenced
by its seven percent score on rotten
tomatoes as of june 2022 it's cruz's
lowest rated movie on the review
aggregator based on haywood gould's
semi-autobiographical novel the same
name cocktail centers around brian
flanagan played by tom cruise a
bartender who dreams of becoming a
salesman on wall street unfortunately
the top sales firms only want to hire
people with experience in college
degrees so he pursues his fortune by
opening beach bars and flirting with the
gigolo lifestyle along the way he
befriends a veteran bartender called
duck played by brian brown falls in love
with a woman named jordan played by
elizabeth shu and makes some costly
mistakes it's an experience to say the
least is cocktail the best movie and
cruises body of work absolutely not but
the film is far too entertaining to be
cruz's lowest ranked movie
eyes open
cocktail is loaded with memorable
moments that typify 80s cinema at its
most excessive and ridiculous and that's
a good thing if you can appreciate a
little bit of cheese in your cinematic
diet characters juggling beer bottles at
the bar like they're performing at a
circus check bartenders performing
alcohol-themed poetry to a nightclub
full of wealthy socialites check fist
fights or art exhibits check throw in a
hip 80s soundtrack and crew singing
robert palmer is addicted to love and
what you have is a recipe for success
there's no denying that cocktail is a
cheesy flick at times however when you
strip away the allure of the sunny
beaches romantic waterfalls and flashy
cocktail bars you'll find a story about
a flawed man who undergoes an
interesting transformation when we first
meet brian he's a materialistic
womanizer who only cares about making
money which causes him to demonstrate
some self-destructive behaviors by the
end he's a changed man who values more
substantial things such as love and
family cocktail isn't particularly deep
but it doesn't gloss over some of the
warts and all elements of the
protagonist's topsy-turvy journey the
original screenplay was a complicated
story about the dark side of power and
money but when disney boarded the
project those elements were toned down
as the studio wanted the characters to
be more likable and hopeful still some
of those themes and ideas are still
apparent in the version of cocktail that
exists today doug's death for example is
particularly upsetting though it does
drive home the film's core message about
the dangers of excess and living a
vacuous empty life for a movie that was
marketed as a lighthearted rom-com
cocktail still possesses a cynical
streak furthermore the film's total
shifts flow together pretty seamlessly
which is remarkable considering that it
can shift from a ridiculous moment to a
harrowing one at any given time it'd be
unfair to say that tom cruise makes the
same movie over and over again after all
he's probably the best action movie star
in the west renowned for performing his
own risky stunts and going the extra
mile for his fans at the same time some
viewers have pointed out that cruz has
drawn toward playing specific types of
characters and they aren't wrong per se
that's not a bad thing mind you as
audiences can't get enough of him help
me
help you
in the 1980s cruz was prone to playing
ambitious underdogs who wanted to be the
best at their respective locations top
gun for example saw him portray a cocky
pilot who experiences a crisis of
conscience and falls in love his days of
thunder character experiences a similar
arc albeit from behind a race car
steering wheel instead of the cockpit of
a fighter jet cocktail has a similar
framework only set within the world of
bars and clubs cruz carries all these
movies with his trademark charm and his
performance in cocktail plays to his
strengths in short if you're a fan of
movies like top gun and days of thunder
then cocktail will be right up your
alley no matter what the critics say
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one